en Irán las mujeres y los jóvenes se
alzaron en contra del régimen
fundamentalista religioso de la
República islámica en un intento por
reivindicar sus derechos y libertades
este movimiento social comenzó con la
muerte de la joven y Max amen y tras ser
detenida por la policía de la moral
Tenemos reporte de ese Teherán
Colombia es pionera en materia de
derechos sexuales y reproductivos en el
continente americano tras despenalizar
el aborto hasta la semana 24 de
gestación activistas y colectivos
médicos abogan por garantizar este
derecho a las mujeres colombianas
especialmente a las más vulnerables
y el mundo de la cultura celebra el
regreso total de la presencialidad tras
más de dos años con muchas restricciones
debido a la pandemia de Kobe 19 los
espectáculos fueron protagonistas
durante todo este 2022 con miles de
conciertos y ferias culturales alrededor
del mundo
Hola Sean bienvenidos a este noticiero
especial en donde recopilamos algunos de
los hechos o que resaltaron durante todo
2022 por tener un carácter positivo para
ciertos sectores de la sociedad
comenzamos en Irán donde las mujeres y
los jóvenes de ese país se alzaron
contra el régimen fundamentalista
religioso de la República islámica en un
intento por reivindicar sus derechos y
pedir libertades en decisiones tan
cotidianas como el uso del yape en las
calles desde Teherán nuestra
corresponsal Catalina Gómez Ángel nos
cuenta más de esta lucha
Irán no volverá a ser el mismo país que
comenzó este año del calendario
occidental porque el de ellos terminará
el 21 de marzo y esto es consecuencia de
esas grandes movilizaciones que
surgieron como consecuencia de la muerte
de Max a mini esa joven de 22 años que
venía del kurdistán y que como muchas
otras mujeres en las grandes ciudades
fue capturada por una patrulla de la
policía de la moral y dos días pues
murió estas movilizaciones lideradas por
mujeres pero especialmente por mujeres
muy jóvenes y también acompañadas por
otros hombres y universitarios Incluso
en los Colegios han ido cambiando la
estructura de este país especialmente la
relación como gran parte de la sociedad
ve hoy al sistema de la república
islámica que ha respondido con una gran
gran represión al menos 490 personas
habrían fallecido hasta el momento según
organizaciones de Derechos Humanos
18.000 personas especialmente jóvenes
están en prisión Y al menos dos de ellos
han sido ya sentenciados a muerte ya han
fallecido lo que ha causado una gran
indignación en la sociedad que ve esto
como actos de desafío de la república
islámica que intenta mandar un mensaje a
esa sociedad de que ellos no van a
cambiar miles y miles de mujeres se han
quitado el velo en las últimas semanas
pero la República islámica a pesar de
que ha sacado a la policía la de las
calles Está tratando de buscar
alternativas Para volver a imponer el
uso de ese velo y la gran pregunta es
logrará hacerlo y logrará cambiar
realmente estas protestas que si bien no
siguen masivamente en las calles siguen
activas en las redes sociales en los
metros en las universidades y en el
corazón de muchos iraníes que no
perdonan esta represión Y estos
asesinatos de la república islámica Y es
que una de las noticias más importantes
de este 2022 sin duda fue la guerra en
Ucrania pero en medio del conflicto la
solidaridad entre los primeros meses
marcó la diferencia tal fue el caso de
los ciudadanos polacos que abrieron las
puertas de sus casas para [__] a los
refugiados ucranianos que huían de la
guerra y otros sirvieron como
voluntarios en cada una de sus
especialidades veamos
los polacos demostraron su gran
solidaridad fue un año difícil para los
ucranianos que gracias a sus vecinos en
Polonia se hizo un poco más llevadero
justo después del inicio de la guerra de
Rusia contra Ucrania trenes procedentes
del beef y que llegaron a diario al
sureste de Polonia
allí voluntarios recibieron en refugios
a aquellos que huían del horror de la
guerra
ofrecemos ayuda médica también hay
dentistas una guardería para niños
hacemos conciertos también Tratamos de
integrar profesionalmente a estas
personas tanto como sea posible les
buscamos trabajo o actividades para que
se sientan útiles
tenemos mucho cuidado de crear un
ambiente cordial y familiar aquí para
que estas personas puedan sentirse como
en casa al menos un poco
por la acogida el alcalde de Varsovia
informó que la población de la capital
se incrementó en hasta un 15% Y aunque
esto supuso un gran reto logístico los
polacos mostraron su buena disposición
ejemplo de ello Es este grupo de 20
mujeres que en un convoy de 7 furgonetas
entregó ayuda humanitaria a lo largo de
4.000 kilómetros en Polonia
nos conmueve especialmente ver a tantos
de ustedes y que hayan abierto sus
corazones los polacos sentimos que ya no
estamos solos porque hasta ahora nos
sentíamos muy solos
Mientras tanto en Polonia alrededor de
un millón quinientos mil ucranianos
esperan así los según Naciones Unidas y
muchos de los exiliados anhelan retornar
a su país en 2023
Colombia se ubicó en 2022 como pionera
en materia de derechos sexuales y
reproductivos en el continente americano
después de que en febrero el órgano
judicial colombiano sacará el código
penal Es delito de aborto hasta la
semana 24 de gestación
estas eran Lágrimas de felicidad después
de una larga espera el 22 de febrero la
corte constitucional de Colombia sacó
del Código Penal la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo hasta la semana
24 de gestación entonces saludamos este
hecho histórico porque es un
reconocimiento a los derechos de las
mujeres un fallo sin precedentes en
América Latina y el fruto de la férrea
lucha de los colectivos feministas
locales más de 100 organizaciones unidas
en el movimiento causa justa Grecia es
también una invitación
cada vez más los procesos de
movilización Social del sur global o
tener experiencias de reflexión
intercambio Sur ya en 2006 lograron la
sentencia c355 por la que el aborto
estaba permitido dentro de un sistema de
tres causales el mismo que impera ahora
si una mujer quiere Acceder al aborto
fuera de los plazos legales algo que
sucede en menos del 1% de los casos el
extenso y criticado plazo señalan desde
las organizaciones es imprescindible
para poder garantizar este derecho a las
mujeres niñas y adolescentes de la
ruralidad indígenas migrantes o
afrocolombianas que todavía se enfrentan
con múltiples barreras porque finalmente
lo que se viola aquí y el derecho que se
violera es el derecho a la salud
Colombia se convierte así en un modelo
en la regularización de los derechos
sexuales y reproductivos pero todavía
arrastra El desafío de la
despenalización social del aborto y la
garantía de un acceso universal
y buenas noticias para la comunidad
afroamericana de Estados Unidos con la
llegada de que tangible
jueza negra en la corte actualmente de
mayoría conservadora Jackson de 52 años
es la cuesta número 117 del supremo y
entró en reemplazo de Stephen magistrado
para el que alguna vez trabajó y quién
se jubiló Brown Jackson es además fue
esa Federal desde el año 2013 y se unió
a otras tres mujeres siendo la primera
vez que cuatro servirán juntas en el
tribunal de 9 integrantes
vamos ahora con noticias económicas
porque la inflación y la devaluación de
las monedas fueron la constante en
América Latina durante 2022 sin embargo
la región se vio en parte favorecida por
la producción de alimentos y materias
primas en varios países cuyos precios
subieron muchos de ellos debido a la
guerra en Ucrania para explicarnos más
esta situación nos acompaña en nuestro
estudio nuestra periodista de economía
Daniela hablandon Daniela explíquenos
Entonces qué está pasando en la región
en temas de inflación Hola Raúl pues no
se puede decir que 2022 haya sido un
buen año para la economía mundial sería
una mentira decirlo pero sí América
Latina de alguna manera se ha rescatado
Y es que según los pronósticos del fondo
monetario internacional
Esta es la única región a la que le han
venido subiendo esa proyección de
crecimiento y va a estar por encima del
resto del mundo 3,5% este año es la
previsión frente a un 3,2% que va a
crecer el mundo esto por qué se da Raúl
porque mire tenemos a Chile que es el
mayor exporta mundial y productor
mundial de cobre y Perú que es el
segundo productor mundial de cobre
tenemos a Colombia que es el quinto
mayor exportador de Carbón y las
materias primas pues este año han subido
de precio Venezuela que tiene mucho
petróleo se estima que tiene las
reservas más grandes de petróleo o
Brasil que es el mayor productor de café
junto con Estados Unidos y Argentina
también son los mayores productores de
soya y los animales los alimentos por
supuesto han venido subiendo a lo largo
de este año Bolivia es un gran productor
de oro también entonces eso le ha
permitido la región crecer más sin
embargo la inflación sigue alta Dani que
va a pasar con esto bueno la inflación
sigue alta tenemos tasas de dos dígitos
en la región en varios países sin
embargo hay que destacar algo en América
Latina y es que los bancos centrales han
sido muy juiciosos en comenzar a subir
las tasas de interés para frenar
precisamente esa inflación y lo hicieron
inclusive antes de que la reserva
Federal comenzara esta subida agresiva
de tasas de interés y muchos economistas
destacado eso de América Latina que
comenzaron con ese antídoto contra la
inflación mucho antes de que empezaran
otras economías más desarrolladas sin
embargo tenemos la inflación más alta en
20 años
No todo está perdido todo está perdido
Así es como siempre Gracias por
acompañarnos en temas económicos Dani
Así es Y nos veremos para más noticias
económicas así en salud en este 2022 por
primera vez secuenció el genoma humano
al completo un logro trascendente en la
ciencia que desbloqueó el 100% de
nuestro ADN hasta ahora dos décadas de
esfuerzo habían logrado esclarecer en un
92% pero quedaban por fuera las regiones
más difíciles por ser altamente
repetitivas los investigadores lo
describieron como hacer un rompecabezas
de un cielo azul gracias a la
coordinación de un centenar
diecientíficos los secretos de este 8%
restante podrán ser investigados y
podrían revelar puntos clave en la
evolución humana del proceso del
envejecimiento o del componente genético
del cáncer
en noticias de ciencia y tecnología
resaltamos los avances del telescopio
espacial James webb que desde que brindó
la primera imagen en alta calidad del
universo en julio no deja de mostrar
fotografías del espacio que nos asombran
cada vez que son publicadas
también Hablamos de los pasos de la NASA
Para volver a llevar al hombre a la luna
a la cápsula no tripulada orión de la
operación artemis 1 volvió ya a la
tierra traza un mes de viaje por el
espacio se trata de la primera prueba
para poder mandar a los astronautas al
satélite de la tierra en el año 2025
26 días después de su lanzamiento al
espacio la NASA lo consiguió la cápsula
orión volvió a la tierra y amerizó en el
océano Pacífico cerrando el primer
capítulo de la operación artemis 1 orión
de vuelta en la tierra la hora oficial
del amerizaje las 11:40 y 30 segundos
la nave no tripulada entró a la
atmósfera terrestre a más de 39 mil
kilómetros por hora probando uno de los
objetivos del viaje que la cápsula podía
aguantar hasta 2760 grados Celsius al
entrar en la atmósfera y chocar con las
moléculas de aire
junto al éxito imágenes memorables por
la ventana de orión una tierra cada vez
más grande y silencio abrumador ahora el
programa artemis sucesor de Apolo está
un poco más cerca de su objetivo volver
a llevar astronautas a la luna después
de 50 años una misión con la que muchos
han llegado a preguntarse Por qué volver
a la Luna si la NASA ya consiguió llegar
hasta allí pero lo cierto Es que artemis
1 artemis 2 y artemis 3 que será la
misión que llevará a cuatro astronautas
a la luna en 2025 va mucho más allá se
espera que los astronautas se
acostumbren a vivir en el espacio y
desarrollan ciencia y tecnología para un
objetivo mucho más grande poder enviar a
los primeros Humanos a Marte
el final de este primer vuelo coincide
con una fecha muy especial el 50
aniversario del alunizaje del Apolo 17
la última vez que los astronautas de la
NASA caminaron por la luna y ahora un
poco más cerca de volver a hacerlo
y la cultura y los espectáculos fueron o
protagonistas Durante este año la
reducción de los casos de covid 19 y el
relajamiento de las restricciones a
nivel global permitieron que la
Industria Del entretenimiento volverá a
reunir a sus espectadores luego de meses
de parálisis por la pandemia
la anhelada normalidad volvió a hacer
una realidad 2022 fue un gran año para
el entretenimiento uno de los sectores
más golpeados por la pandemia el público
volvió a reunirse de manera presencial
para disfrutar de conciertos
espectáculos y eventos culturales
dejando atrás el aforo limitado el uso
de mascarillas obligatorios y los
protocolos de bioseguridad y todo
sucedió mucho más rápido de lo
pronosticado
con seguridad nunca
lo virtual va a reemplazar a lo
presencial volvimos volvimos a salir y
eso se nota Y eso se ve en una ciudad
por ejemplo como Bogotá este año con un
flujo de eventos increíbles Teníamos dos
y tres artistas de talla internacional
en un mismo fin de semana en concierto
la mayoría de países relajó sus medidas
contra el covid 19 gracias a la
disminución de casos positivos dando
paso a festivales como Rocky río y
lulapalusa e incluso a eventos
literarios como la feria del libro de
Guadalajara que reunió a más de 8005.000
amantes de las letras en un mismo lugar
y ya este 2022 efectivamente regresamos
a la presencia a la presencialidad pero
ya sin restricciones ni límites de aforo
eso nos permitió tener una una feria que
regresó a la alegría prepandémica por
decirlo de alguna manera que nos
permitió reencontrarnos con muchísima
alegría
para 2023 se espera que los eventos
culturales continúen abiertos al público
e incluso la industria prevé un
incremento de Hasta el 6%
hasta aquí este informato y especial
continúe con nosotros en France 24